[تصفيق]
يومان لكيف في بوخارست في اجتماعات
العاصمه الرومانيه مساحه لعرض تماسك حلف
الناتو ووحده موقفه تجاه الحرب في
اوكرانيا
اريد اللقاء ان يكون منصه لحشد مزيد من
الدعم للاكرانيين
ولانه غزو فاشل فقد صرنا نشهد مزيدا من
الوحشيه التي تستهدف مرافق الغاز وامدادات
الطاقه ومحاولات حرمان الاخرانيين من
الكهربائي والتدفئه مستقبلا نحن بحاجه الى
مزيد من دعم اوكرانيا لاننا نلحظ وان
الرئيس يستخدم
مزيدا من المعاناه للشعب الاوكراني سريعا
تحول الانشغال الى تعهدات جديده من وزراء
خارجيه الحلف فهم يرون ان الهجمات الروسيه
المستمره على البنيه التحتيه المدنيه وتلك
الخاصه بالطاقه في اوكرانيا تحريم ملايين
الاوكرانيين من الخدمات الانسانيه
الاساسيه
لذلك تقرر تكليف الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا
والمساعده في اصلاح بنيتها التحتيه للطاقه
بينما تواصل بحسب بيان الحلف الدفاع عن
سيادتها وسلامه اراضيها
يدرك حلفاؤكيف الغربيون بان المساعدات
جميعها ما زالت دونها مشكلات تتعلق
بالامداد والطاقه الانتاجيه
لكنهم في اجتماع الحلف واجتماعي مجموعه
السبعه الذي يرتبه الالمان على هامشه
يبحثون تذليله تلك العقبه
فذاك مما قد يعين الاوكرانيين على الصمود
ويسرع وتيره ترميم البينه التحتيه للطاقه
في بلادهم
للغايه نفسها تعد واشنطن بحسب مسؤولين
امريكيين لمنحي كيف مساعده ماليه طارئه
تواجه بها ما يصفه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
باعتداءات بوتين في اوكرانيا تلك التي
يؤكد بلنكن تصميم الحلف على مواجهتها
على هذا الموقف الغربي بالذات لكن نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي يرى انه لا حوار مع
واشنطن بخصوص اوكرانيا لان المواقف كما
قال تختلف بشكل جذري ان نهجو الامريكي
لتصعيد النزاع في اوكرانيا يقول سر رياض
كفر محفوف بعواقبه وخيمه